هجوم ليلي جديد على شرق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كاف بصواريخ روسيه يؤدي لمقتل
ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اخرين
باغلبيه كبيره مجلس النواب الامريكي يقر
مشروع قانون تعليق سقف الدين العام وبايدن
يرحب بتلك الخطوه التي وصفها بالاساسيه
لقاء مرتقب المغرب بين رئيسين مجلس النواب
والدوله عقيل صالح والمشري للتوافق على
حكومه ليبيه تشرف على الانتخابات المقرره
نهايه العام
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الاخباريه من العربيه اعلن مسؤلون في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه هجوما روسيا بالصواريخ
على المدينه اسفر عن مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص
بينهم طفلان واصابه 14 شخصا اخرين قالت
الاداره العسكريه في منشور على التيليجرام
ان اثنين من القتلى من الاطفال في الهجوم
الذي استهدف منطقه على الاطراف الشرقيه
للعاصمه كذلك منطقه
وهي اكثر قربا من وسط المدينه يعد هذا
الهجوم الثامن عشر على العاصمه كييف هذا
الشهر
على الجانب الاخر علينا حاكمه مدينه
بلكرود الروسيه فيتسلاف كلاتكو فانه من
يرغب بمغادره مدينه شيكينو يمكنه التقدم
لبلديه المدينه وسينال المساعده قال
الحاكم ان الوضع في المدينه مخيف حقا
بالنسبه للاطفال وكبار السن وللجميع ولهذا
اتخذنا قرارا بمساعده كل من يرغب بمغادره
المدينه مؤقتا اشار الى ان القوات الروسيه
في المنطقه عاملت جيدا على نقل النساء
والاطفال وكبار السن عندما دخلوا مقاتلون
اوكرانيون الى جرايفورون وكان حاكم
المدينه قدم تقريرا لبوتين حول الوضع في
الاقليم حيث تعرضت المنطقه لقصف شديد طال
اطراف الاقليم الغربيه والجنوبيه
من جانبه اعلن منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي في
البيت الابيض جون كيرلي ان الولايات
المتحده خصصت لاوكرانيا حزمه المساعدات
عسكريه جديده تشمل منظومات صواريخ ستينغار
المحموله ومنظومات دفاع جوي من طراز افنجر
وصواريخ المنظومات باتريوت قال كيربي ان
الولايات المتحده تعتزم مواصله دعم
اوكرانيا
وعاقبه تعرض العاصمه الروسيه موسكو لهجمات
بالمسيرات اكد المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن
القومي الامريكيربي ان واشنطن لا تؤيد
الضربات الاوكرانيه على الاراضي الروسيه
ولا توجه الاوكرانيين لكيفيه اجراء
عملياتها عمليتهم انما هي توفر لهم
المعدات وتمنحهم التدريب المناسب فقط
استهداف موسكو ولسنا معنيين بالتحقيق في
هذا الامر فنحن لا نوجه الاوكرانيين
لكيفيه اجراء عملياتهم ولا نحدد لهم
اهدافهم نحن نوفر لهم المعدات ونمنحهم
التدريب المناسب ونقدم حتى المشوره
لمساعدتهم على التخطيط
على صعيد اخر اتهمت القوات الروسيه في
سوريا طيارين الامريكيين بارتكاب انتهاكات
جسيمه للبروتوكولات المراد بها تجنب
الصدام بين القوتين العظميين ونقلت وكاله
الاعلام الروسيه عن ادميرالوف رئيس مركز
المصالحه الروسي في سوريا قوله ان
الطيارين الامريكيين نشطوا انظمه اسلحتهم
اثناء اقترابهم من الطائرات الروسيه فوق
شرق البلاد
صوت مجلس نواب الامريكي على تمريعه مشروع
سقف الدين بحصوله على 314 صوتا مقابل 117
صوتا وصوت لصالح المشروع 149 نائبا
جمهوريا ومئه وخمسه وستون نائبا ديمقراطيا
اي انه مرر باغلبيه اصوات الديمقراطيين
وصوت ضده 71 نائبا جمهوريا وسته واربعون
نائبا ديمقراطيه
وفي اول رد فعل له رحب رئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن بالخطوه التي اتخذها مجلس النواب
باقراره مشروع قانون يعلق العمل حتى 2025
بسقف الدين العام ويجنب الولايات المتحده
التخلف عن سداد ديونها قال بايدن في
بياننا مجلس النواب اتخذ خطوه اساسيه
للحيلوله دون ان تتخلف الولايات المتحده
لاول مره في تاريخها عن سداد ديونها مشددا
على ان الطريق الوحيد للمضي قدما هو تسويه
بين الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
وصف المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي في البيت الابيض جون كيربنسي حب
الجيش مين المفاوضات الهدنه بالامر المؤسف
اضاف جونكر بان القطار بين الجيش بقوه
الدعم السريع يجب ان يتوقف والمساعدات يجب
ان تصل للمتضررين
[موسيقى]
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات
وبعد انباء عن وفاته ظهر القائد الثاني
لقوات الدعم السريع عبد الرحيم زيجلو في
فيديو جديد اكد فيه ان قائد قوات الدعم
السريع محمد حمدانو المعروف بحماتي بخير
ويقاتل مع قوته في الصفوف الاولى على
الارض الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في
الصفوف الاماميه مع قواته والان هربكم
ولكن
البيان للعمل
بعد مشاركته في مشاورات مغلقه في مجلس
الامن الدولي حول السودان قال الامين
العام للامم المتحده انطونيو انه جدد
لاعضاء المجلس تاكيد ثقته التامه في فولكر
بيرت ممثله الخاصه في السودان
فيما يتعلق بالوضع في السودان هناك مجالات
تقع تحت مسؤوليه مجلس الامن واخرى تقع ضمن
مسؤوليه امينه عام الامم المتحده بالنسبه
لمجال مسؤوليتي اعدت التاكيد لاعضاء مجلس
الامن على ثقه التامه في فولكر بيرتز
باعتباره ممثلا خاصا للامين العام الامر
يعود لمجلس الامن بان يقرر ما اذا كان
يدعم استمرار البعثه لفتره اخرى او ان
يقرر ان الوقت قد حان لانهائها
[موسيقى]
اكد مصدر مطلع للعربيه من لجنه 6 + 6
الليبيه بان رئيسي مجلس النواب والدوله
عقيله صالح وخالد المشري سيلتقيان في
المغرب بدايه الاسبوع المقبل من اجل
الاعلان عن التوافق النهائي اضافه المصدر
وان موعد اللقاء لم يحدد بعد بشكل نهائي
في انتظار ان تضع اللجنه ولمسات الاخيره
على الاتفاق بالاضافه الى اعلان تفاهم على
تشكيل حكومه موحده بصلاحيات محدده لتشرفا
على الانتخابات
نا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
نائب رئيس السابق الجمهوري يعلن في السابع
من يونيو القادم انضمامه الى السباق
الرئاسي الامريكي منافسا لحليفه السابق
دونالد ترامب
اهلا بكم من جديد عربه وزير الدفاع
الامريكيه خلال زياره الى طوكيو عن اسفه
لرفض نظيره الصيني الاجتماعي به هذا
الاسبوع لا سيما في ضوء المناورات
الاستفزازيه التي قامت بها مؤخرا مقاتلات
صينيه قرب طائرات عسكريه امريكيه حذر
اوستن من انه بعد عمليه الاعتراض
الاستفزازيه التي نفدتها مقاتلات حربيه
صينيه مؤخرا زاد قلقه من احتمال وقوع حادث
قد يخرج سريعا عن السيطره
كشف مصدر ان او مصدرا مطلعان ان نائب
الرئيس السابق الجمهوري مايك بنس سينضم في
السابعه من يونيو الى السباق الرئاسي لعام
2024 منافسا للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
واضاف المصدرا انا بنز سيطلق حملته سعيا
لنيل ترشيح الحزب الجمهوري بمقطع فيديو
وكلمه يدلي بها في ولايه
حذرت فوكس نيوز الامريكيه من حمله اعلاميه
ممنهجه تهدف لعرقله المرشح
واظهاره على انه خطر على الحريه الفكريه
والاكاديميه في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يبدو ان الصعود الصاروخيه
لشعبيه روندي سانتوس منافس ترامب على
قياده الحزب الجمهوري قد اربكت ديمقراطيين
مثلما اربكت ترامب
تحذر من حمله اعلاميه مسبقه تشنها وسائل
واعلام تحاول عرقله ديسانتس باشاعه انه
اكثر خطرا على الديمقراطيه الامريكيه من
منافسه ترامب مستدله بعدد من المقابلات
والتغريدات التي برزت مؤخرا من صحفيين
ديمقراطيين رعد سعيد
مقربه من الجمهوريين تصف ديسانتس بانه
مستقبل الحزب الشاب الاكثر نجاحا وشعبيه
في البلاد وخير وريث للترامبيه القويه
فيما يحذر ديمقراطيون بان افكار ديسانتس
المتشدده تهدد الحريه الفكريه والاكاديميه
وتنمي قوه التطرف ما قد يدفع البلاد لحرب
اهليه
عوده امريكا العظمى تبدا باعاده جو بايدن
الى قوي منزله بلدنا يسير في الاتجاه
الخاطئ لقد انهارت حدودنا الجنوبيه ملايين
المهاجرين غير الشرعيين والمجرمين على
قوائم الارهاب يدخلون الاف الضحايا من
المخدرات وانظروا الى الاقتصاد اداره
بايدن تفعل كل ما في وسعها لجعل الحياه
اكثر صعوبه للاسر العاديه
سبق وان تحدث عن ميله لاتخاذ تشريعات
صارمه ضد عدد من القضايا التي يعتبرها
الديمقراطيون حريه مثل قضايا الضرائب
والاجهاض والمهاجرين والتعليم وحمل السلاح
شبكه سي ان ال عن مصادر قولها ان الادعاء
الفيدراليه الامريكي حصل على تسجيل صوتي
يقر فيه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
باحتفاضه بوثيقه سريه بشان الهجوم محتمل
على ايران اضافت المصادر ان تسجيلها يمثل
دليلا مهما في قضيه محتمله ضد ترامب
قالت مصادر في حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو ان
اسم رئيس الوزراء الاسباني
طرح على طاوله لتعيينها امينا عاما للحلف
خلفا اليانس غير
تبعد نفسه كبديل محتمل
[موسيقى]
يدرس حلف الناتو تعيين رئيس الوزراء
الاسباني بيدرو سانشيز امنا عاما للحلف
خلفا لامينه الحالي يانستولتنبرغ في مارس
الماضي كان بيدرس انشاز يفكر في رئاسه
دوره كامله لمجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
استبعد نفسه كبديل محتمل الا ان مصادر في
الحلف قالت ان اسمه تم تداوله على الطاوله
بدا سانشيز حياته السياسيه عام 2004 كعضو
في مجلس مدينه مدريد
انتخب لمجلس النواب الاسباني عام 2009
وعام 2014 انتخب امينا عاما لحزب العمال
الاشتراكي الاسباني
قد حزبه الى الفوز في انتخابات عام 2019
وتراس الحكومه الاسبانيه عام 2020
[موسيقى]
اثار ايلون ماسك رئيس تنفيذي لشركه تسلا
دهشه بزيارته الاولى لبكين منذ ثلاث سنوات
ولقائه وزير الخارجيه الصيني في اجتماع
وصفه الخبراء بعالي المخاطر معتبرين ان
زياره ماسك تاتي في مساعد الدخول على خط
التفاهمات بين واشنطن
الشركات الامريكيه الكبرى دخلت على خط
التسويه مع الصين لنزع فتيل الفتنه بين
اكبر اقتصادين في العالم في وقت يحتدم
الصراع بين واشنطن وبيكين زاد من حدته
حادث بالون التجسس الشهير والتوترات حول
شكوك امريكيه بتجسس الصين على واشنطن
والعالم من خلال تيك توك ومع وجود مؤشرات
قليله على المصالحه وبحجه ان للقوى العظمى
مصلحه مشتركه في استمرار التعاون حتى
ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
رحاله في الصين والتقى وزير خارجيتها وهي
احدث عوده لرئيس تنفيذي امريكي كبير الى
الصين والتي اعتبرها الخبراء عاليه
المخاطر في وقت تشتد التراشقات الامريكيه
الصينيه الى اعلى مستوياتها وعلى كافه
الصعد
شركات كبرى سبقت ماسك الى خط المصالحه
كابل وستاربكس وغيرها في دليل واضح على
حاجه السوق الامريكي الى الصين في النمو
فالمصالح الامريكيه والصينيه يراها
الخبراء لا تنفصل عن بعضها البعض
وبمازل عن توجهات قاده البلدين في اداره
الصراع القائم سيستمر الخصمان بالاعتماد
على بعضهما البعض مهما اشتد الصراع بينهما
مع ادراك كبرى الشركات الامريكيه اهميه
الصين في النمو الاقتصادي العالمي ولعدم
حدوث انفجار كبير كارثي قد يوجه اقتصاد
العالم الى مسار لا تحمد عقبه
ما اريد الذكاء الاصطناعي الذي خرج من
القمقم لا يمكن اعادته مجددا بل هو يزداد
قدره وخطوره يوميا وتزداد معه المخاوف من
تهديد البشريه او حتى انقراضها سؤال وجهته
العربيه مباشره للذكاء الاصطناعي كيف يمكن
له القضاء على البشريه
تردد على غير عادته ثم اجاب بالسيناريوهات
مختلفه المزيد مع نادي الخماش القليل من
الفضول دفعنا لسؤال ذكاء الاصطناعي نفسه
من خلال
عن كيفيه انقراض البشريه
نفى قدرته كذكاء الصناعي على التنبؤ
الدقيق بمستقبل البشريه لكنه طرح
سيناريوهات محتمله وصادمه لانقراضنا كبشر
اولها الحرب النوويه واسعه النطاق ثانيها
الكوارث البيئيه وثالثها الاوبئه والامراض
لكن الاخطر بين اجاباته كان الكوارث
التكنولوجيه وهنا قال ان خطا بشريا او
فشلا بالتكنولوجيا الحديثه قد يؤدي
الانهيار الانظمه الحاسوبيه الحيويه
وبالتالي القضاء على البشريه
فسالنا تشاد جي بي تي السؤال الابرز كيف
يمكن للذكاء الاصطناعي ان يقضي على
البشريه التطبيق الذكي وخلافا لسرعته
المعتاده بالاجابه والتي لا تتعدى ثواني
استلزمه اكثر من خمس دقائق قبل الادلاء
بدلوه وقال ان ذكاء الاصطناعي بحد ذاته
ليس مهددا للبشريه بل هو مجرد اداه تعتمد
على كيفيه استخدامها وتصميمها وختم اجابته
بشعار لديك عطل في الشبكه الانترنت اعدنا
السؤال باصرار فاضطر لتعداد السيناريوهات
يمكن وصفها بالمخيفه اولها التمكن الذاتي
اي حين يتمكن ذكاء الاصطناعي من تطوير
نفسه بنفسه باستمرار وبمعدلات هائله وقد
يتحكم في مصائر البشريه بطرق لا يمكن
للبشر ان يت معها اما السيناريو الثاني
وعلى ذمه تشاد هو عدم التفاهم بين ما
يعتبره ذكاء الاصطناعي الافضل للبشريه
وبينما يعتبره البشر الافضل لانفسهم وهنا
تتصادم وتتعارض المصالح وربما تهدد
البشريه اخر السيناريوهات السيطره الشامله
حين يحقق الذكاء الاصطناعي سيطره كامله
على النظام الحاسوبيه والانظمه الاخرى في
العالم مثل بنيه الحكومات وبالتالي يمكنه
قمع البشريه او تدميرها بشكل كامل لم
نستطع تخطي مساله استغراقه وقتا طويلا
للاجابه سالناه عن السبب لياتي الرد ان
السؤال يتعامل مع مساله جديه ومعقده تتعلق
بالحياه البشريه وبمستقبلنا ولا يمكن
التجاوب معها بسطحيه
شرطه الانترنت قادمه تحذير تصدر عناوين
مجله البريطانيه التي نشرت تقريرا نبه الى
تبعات التشريعات التي اقرتها دول حول
العالم تحت زريعه حمايه المستخدمين من
المحتوى الضار والمعلومات المضلله على
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعي المجله قالت ان
المجالس التشريعيه لولايات امريكيه
ومحاكمها ترسم خطوطا جديده حول حدود
التعبير حيث يتفق الديمقراطيون
والجمهوريون على ضروره تغيير قواعد مراجعه
المحتوى على الشبكات الاجتماعيه لكنهم
يختلفون بشان ما يجب فعله حيال ذلك اما في
اوروبا فذهبت الهيئات التشريعيه الى ابعد
من ذلك اذ سيبدا العمل بقانون الخدمات
الرقميه للاتحاد الاوروبي دي اس اي الذي
تم اقراره في يوليو عام 2022 العمل مقبل
في بريطانيا من المتوقع ان يتم سن قانون
السلام على الانترنت الذي تمت صياغته بعد
انتحار مراهق يبلغ 14 عاما بعد ان شاهد
مواد على الانترنت وتشير المجله الى ان
البرازيل اقرت قانون الاخبار الكاذبه الذي
يعاقب الشبكات الاجتماعيه لفشلها في تحديد
المعلومات المضلله كما ستعلن الهند عن
مشروع قانون تنظيم الانترنت في يونيو الذي
يقال انه سيحمل المنصات الاجتماعيه
مسؤوليه محتوى المستخدمين
المثير للقلق ان هذه التحركات تلهم
الحكومات في الاجزاء الاقل ديموقراطيه من
العالم لصياغه قواعد جديده خاصه بها
بين صنعاء وعددا ظل مرضى السرطان من ابناء
مارب ونازحون فيها ينتقلون لتشخيص المرض
وعلاجه وفي ظل تزايد عدد المصابين تم
افتتاح وحده لمعالجه الاورام تخفف على
المرضى اعباء السفر وحدات تفتقر للكثير من
الامكانيات لكنها تمثل نواه لافتتاح مركز
متخصص لعلاج الاورام بحسب السلطه المحليه
في سن الاربعه اعوام يعاني الطفل يعقوب من
سرطان الدم ومع تلقيه جرعات كيماويه في
صنعاء عادت حركته الطبيعيه بعد اشهر من
فقدان الامل في التعافي
يعقوب طفل من النازحين في مارب يعاني
الالاف منهم امراضا مزمنه وحالات سرطان
متفاوته الخطوره في ظل غياب كلي لعياده
كشف ومعالجه السرطان خلال الفتره الماضيه
سويت له فحوصات في كل المختبرات اللي
موجوده في مارب ما توصلت لها مده اربع
شهور كان ولدي هذا يعتبر مقعد قد هو مقعد
طلع الفراش رحت صنعاء وديتهم مستشفى
الكويت وطلع في سرطان فحص الاول والفحص
الثاني
انه سرطان سرطان في الدم
[موسيقى]
يتم استقبال المريض وفحصه وقبل اعطاء
الجرعه
وتحضيره للعلاج اعطال الجرعه التمهيديه
قبل العلاج الكيماوي ثم بعد ذلك يتم
مراقبته واعطاء العلاج الكيماوي لدينا
احصائيه اوليه من محافظه مارب يحول ما
يقارب 120 مريض سرطان خلال الفتره السابقه
الماضيه
فهناك حاجه ملحه وضروريه في محافظه مارب
لا يوجد وحده او عياده حتى عياده تخصصيه
لعلاج السرطان
127 حاله من مرضى السرطان في مديريات مارب
الثلاث المجاوره لشركات الاستكشافات
والانتاج النفطي رصدتهم منظمه محليه فيما
توفي المئات وربما الالاف من الحالات في
مخيمات النزوح قبل تشخيص الاورام محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
اعلنت كيميو جونغ شقيقه زعيم الكوريه
الشمالي كيم جون اون ان قمر التجسس
العسكري لبلادها سيدخل قريبا في المدار
وتعهدت بتكثيف جهود المراقبه العسكريه
وقالت في بياننا اعداء كوريا الشماليه
يخشون وصولها الى وسائل الاستطلاع
والمعلومات الفائقه بما في ذلك قمار
التجسس وبناء عليه فان بيون بيانج ستركز
جهودا اكبر لتطوير هذه الوسائل
في نهايه النشره تفكيرهم بابرز العناوين
هجوم ليلي جديد على شرق العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف لم يتضح مصدره للان يؤدي
لمقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اخرين
باغلبيه كبيره مجلس النواب الامريكي يقر
مشروع قانون تعليق سقف الدين العام وبايدن
يرحب بتلك الخطوه التي وصفها بالاساسيه
لقاء مرتقب بالمغرب بين رئيسين مجلس
النواب والدوله عجل صالح والمشري للتوافق
على حكومه ليبيه تشرف على الانتخابات
المقررات نهايه العالم
نهايه النشره في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات